je suis marié papa de quatre enfants de
16 à 12 ans j'habite le chesnay depuis
bientôt une dizaine d'années
et je co dirige une entreprise qui gère
des échanges de données électroniques en
entreprise
une mère tous les trois tous les trois
ont commencé
et de quelles personnes âgées
normal car c'est le deuxième spectacle
d'une troupe qui s'appelle mon cher
théophile qui a été créé il ya quelques
années maintenant à l'initiative d'un
paroissien de garches
qui avaient répondu à l'appel de
l'évêque du diocèse de nanterre de
trouver des nouveaux moyens
d'évangéliser et donc eric libaud
celi tiens pourquoi pas faire un
spectacle musical
et sa première idée était de faire un
spectacle musical sur les actes des
apôtres le préfet y en a parlé c'est
dans un train de banlieue bien j'ai
écrit quelque chose je pensais à toi
pour tel rôle et studio est sympa
allons-y que j'aime bien chanter n'avait
ni leur ensemble de metz je suis sympa
moi
marché qu'on était parti pour faire
d'augmentation sur une saison et puis
finalement dans la fin du double et puis
on a fait en deuxième saison des grandes
salles beaucoup de spectateurs ça c'est
un autre aspect que ce qui est très
important enfin qu'eric a souligné
souvent là que le niveau d'exigence nous
met au niveau d'un spectacle proviseur
avec les compétences qu'on a parce qu on
n ont pas professionnel la deuxième
saison dans laquelle on entend des
grandes salles comme le palais des
congrès l'olympia ou le zénith à
toulouse a permis de drainer des gens
qui seraient pas venus dans les petites
salles combien la première année moi
j'ai eu des collègues de travail des
associés qui ont pu devenir l'un des
deux saisons parce que c'était le palais
des congrès est sorti parce que c'est un
vainqueur et ce qui a été
particulièrement enfin frappant ou
touchant cesser tous les messages qu'on
a pu recevoir de gens qui sont venus
voir le spectacle qui plus ou moins
proche de l'église - investi plus ou
moins croyants et qui ont été touchées
d'une manière ou d'une autre part par le
message qui était qui étaient portés
dans le spectacle il ya eu un vrai un
vrai impact je pense d'évangélisation ou
en tout cas de de booster un peu les
gens qui venaient voir le spectacle dans
l'eau dans leur foi
d'être plongé dans la parole des lieux
une fois deux fois trois fois cinq fois
par semaine plus du dimanche c'est
forcément porteur
en plus dangour assez vrai qu'on est on
était vraiment voilà on jouait
la vie de ces premiers apôtres qui était
quand même
tumultueuse difficile
à croire et suivre le christ à l'époque
c'était c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
que qu'aujourd'hui en finlande en cours
à allah les apôtres sont maltraités
milan prison
samart d'une part faire redécouvrir
certains passages de l'écriture je
connaissais pas bien enfin que tu
partais avec des apôtres que
peu voire pas du tout
d'ailleurs avec certains passages qui
sont étonnants que quand j'ai lu le
script la première fois du rôle futur et
du coup après j'ai fait vraiment c'est
vrai c'est bien marquer
la manière vraiment douvres a été ajouté
et s'est poursuivie il y avait vraiment
une volonté est forte d'inscrire son nom
dans la prière avant toute répétition
générale et avant tout trouver entation
de manière certaine et à prière en
commun avec tous les participants et
tous les soirs de représentation il y
avait adoration par un certain nombre de
communautés religieuses qui le dit
supporter bras et qu'ils porteront malka
aussi pendant tout le vol spectacle
je jouais le personnage de saint pierre
bois
saint pierre c'est une baisse des impôts
est quelqu'un d'assez impulsif de ces
entier qui est un peu colérique et donc
il ya dans l'action qui est un peu
impulsif c'était pas ma nature donc il a
fallu qu'une et m
cette fois ci le personnage est très
différent qui en équipe avec deux autres
personnes qui impose le fil rouge du
spectacle mais un peu en dehors du temps
un peu en dehors des scènes qui
interagit avec les prophètes qui ont
accompagné aller vite évident on me sale
gueule et nathan et et d'une inventivité
incroyable tous les instruments qui
passait à sa portée est très bon pour
rendre gloire à dieu voilà on apprend
juste à la fin qui sont ces trois
personnes je peux juste dire qu'elles
ont un accoutrement assez particulier
qui veut qu'on ne peut pas les rater
personnes s'attendaient à ce que cela
allait être en termes de charge de
travail donc en jeu j'en ai parlé à
sophie au début aucun aucun souci et
puis passer monter graduellement
jusqu'à la fin c'était vraiment très
très très chargé ont le rythme s'est
intensifiée je suis au moins une semaine
on a joué cinq répétitions de la semaine
la deuxième saison du roi était beaucoup
moins d'augmentation qui ont connaissez
spectacle donc c'était c'était plus
légers déjà et pour malka s'est encore
plus léger donc alors j'ai quand même
demandé l'autorisation à ce fils
recommencer et j'ai dit oui il ya moins
de répétition il émane et les moins
absents et je trouve que c'est plus
facile pour la vie de famille et puis le
fait qu audrey soit aussi participantes
dans le spectacle je trouve que ça fait
une vraie cohésion entre eux que ils ont
leur moment tous les deux il ya de la
complicité ils peuvent se parler de
certains moments du spectacle et je
trouve que c'est un vrai apport pour la
famille
et non
on
oh
à